we're joined Now by mwan bashara Al's
senior political analyst and mwan we're
hearing that the Israeli War cabinet the
Prime Minister the defense minister
another Minister a meeting yet again on
Thursday we might hear from them later
but before um before we hear from them
we've already heard from the defense
minister yet again saying that after the
ceasefire ends the fighting with Hamas
will continue because their objective is
to destroy Hamas and he went on to give
a little bit more detail than he had on
on Wednesday by saying that he
anticipates that the fighting could last
another two months I mean what do you
make of the defense minister saying this
on the eve of a ceasefire deal well
clearly that the Israelis are trying to
justify for themselves why uh they had
to do the pause that they were
essentially and principally against it's
only under pressure by a certain segment
of the public opinion within Israel and
certain pressure by the United States
that they finally accepted those four
days maybe they could be extended for
one or two or three more days but in the
end of the day uh the Israeli military
and political establishment want to
continue with the war they insist on
continuing with the war and
uh basically um achieve its objectives
right which is presumably to defeat
Hamas now uh a lot of Israelis now from
the southern part of Israel and the
northern part of Israel as you know have
been displaced into the center of is
Israel although they are staying in
hotels and on the likes they are uh
complaining uh so Israel needs to give
some sort of a signal how long will this
take and how uh much of a damage will it
cause the economy because as we know the
economy is taking a beating in Israel
now some talk about a quarter of a
million dollar losses a day there's also
a signal to the United States that this
is not an open-ended war that if it took
six weeks to where we are today another
two months perhaps and of course for the
rest of us who are keeping score of the
incredible uh death and destruction that
is taking place another two months means
the actual flattening and destroying of
Gaza yeah absolutely and on the subject
of signaling to the United States
Israeli media is also reporting that
prime minister Netanyahu spoke to US
President Joe Biden on the phone on
Wednesday and that Biden asked nahu he
encouraged a truce in the north with
Hezbollah do you think that the United
States is really putting any pressure on
Israel to stop this conflict from
spilling over into the region you know
in the beginning uh at least the first
five six weeks I was thinking that
President Biden has boxed himself in
behind Netanyahu giving him
unconditional support despite the war
crimes it was signaling to other powers
around the world that once the United
States commits to support for example
Ukraine against Russia or Israel in the
Middle East that it would not stop
despite the price to its
credibility uh but now uh it's clear
that uh Biden wants to see an end to
this and clearly Biden has um you know a
sort of a wider lens than Netanyahu he
sees that the future of Israel in the
Middle East is at risk and all these
agreements that Israel signed with Arab
countries are at risk and that those
potential agreement with Saudi Arabia is
no
longer in the Horizon under the
circumstance and hence Biden is actually
thinking of Israel's interest not of
just America's interest and its own
standing in the world and he sees that
the price is far exceeds far the
objectives and that the the death and
the destruction will come back and haunt
him and haunt America's credibility and
hence he wants to see a certain things
happen he wants to see the war being
runed up he would like to see uh not
widening in the north and certainly he
would like to see certain red lines that
we've heard the Secretary of State
repeat once and again albe it rejected
by Israel and these are three one no
occupation of Gaza after the war no
ethnic cleansing of the Palestinians uh
during the war and no shrinking of the
territory of Gaza under the pretext of
say security zones and the likes so uh
clearly there's some daylight now uh and
that's kind of increasing with time
between the United States and Israel
because Israel is
blindly uh carrying its genocide against
the Palestinians with absolutely no
understanding of the consequences what
does this mean for the region and for
its allies because the war crimes that
are being carried will have implications
will have repercussions in the region
and Beyond Maran thank you very much for
that that's our senior political analyst
Madan
Bashar